[Music]
are you ready for the uk transition
number three continuing to trade
hello my name is jane rose and i'm head
of international trade at the essex
chambers of commerce
this is a third of four bite-sized
videos about the uk transition
which have been commissioned by the
rochford district council to help
businesses prepare for the changes
to trading with the eu in this video
i'm going to talk about how to help you
continue to export an import with the eu
next year
we want to help you get ready if this is
new to you
it can be daunting but don't worry share
the burden with your colleagues
contact and website details are listed
in the video description
so what do you need to do now to prepare
to continue trading with the eu from
january 2021
the first thing you'll need to do is
check that you have a uk
iori number which stands for economic
operators registration and
identification number if you have it
will start with a gb
and include your vat number if not then
apply now
it's quick and easy to do anything you
import or export to the eu will require
a customs declaration from the 1st of
january
for imports you may be able to delay the
full import declaration for six months
but you'll need to find out if your
goods qualify first
and remember you'll have to make the
full declaration by first of july next
year
if your goods qualify and you do want to
delay the declaration
you or your agent broker will need to
look into opening a duty deferment
account
as mentioned in my previous video you'll
need to complete the form
c88 or sad a single administrative
document
to make customs declarations you should
think carefully about who will make
these declarations
to do it yourself you'll need training
specialist software
and the import badge for the relevant
port of entry
you can appoint somebody to make the
declaration for you
a customs broker an agent or a forwarder
but either way there is time and cost
involved
the british chamber of commerce network
do offer a custom service
so please get in touch if you'd like to
know more
if you do decide to use a third party to
make declarations
it's important to check that the
information you give to them is correct
you're responsible not them you'll need
to know the commodity codes to classify
and value the goods that you're
importing or exporting
this code will give you information on
duties
vat licence requirements quotas and more
you can find these codes on the uk
global tariff for imports and the
exporters trade tool
the links are on our website you'll also
need to look at how you are going to
handle vat
you may want to use postponed accounting
there are custom special procedures
which can reduce
the duty you pay in some circumstances
so i would look into how this could
benefit you
you'll need to keep records for four
years even if somebody else makes the
declaration for you
it's really important in case you have
future customs audits
speak with your logistics provider too
as there are changes and regulations
that they need to be aware of such as
international driving permits
and the new goods vehicle movement
system
the government border operating model
has more information
on all of these topics that was a very
basic run-through
of some of the things that you'll need
to think about but don't be put off
start to prepare now and remember there
is help available
you can contact us at the essex chambers
of commerce if you need some guidance or
training
contact and website details are listed
in the video description
thank you so much for listening
[Music]